et maintenant
voici jean claude brialy
là ça va bien oui j'ai regardé un peu
l'émission c'est un peu mais 68,1 et
c'est bien ça démarrage année mais
surtout certains oui certains c'est vrai
que monsieur comme comme guy je préfère
les films 1
le goupil il est sincère il est
romantique
il m'a fait penser à sa juste mais très
bien connu alors on va commencer pour se
mettre en jambe par quelques part
quelques questions de journalistes
débutants messaoud je sais pas si ça
vous hyde non mais ça va ça m'est arrivé
ya maintenant 50 ans les journalistes
débutants c'est à dire les mecs qui vous
disent par exemple jean claude brialy
vous faisiez quoi avant de faire des
séries télé un petit peu de cinéma est
ce que vous faites maintenant c'est un
choix et une vocation locale ou bien
vous pensez vous avez enfin trouver
votre voie après toutes ces années je
crois pas remédier aux étoiles payer les
joueurs très espiègle et les gens à la
mort meeting aussi en tout cas pour toi
est ce que vous pensez être un modèle
pour les gens qui vous admirent
j'espère un votre carrière c'est un coup
de chance ou beaucoup de boulot c'est
beaucoup de chance et beaucoup de boulot
ouais quels conseils donneriez-vous à un
jeune comédien qui débute ne couchez pas
quels conseils donneriez vous à un vieux
comédien qui débute
friess ayant encore un petit coup 1 et
quels conseils donneriez-vous un
comédien qui se fout complètement de la
vie de jean claude brialy
tu as raison quels conseils
donneriez-vous un vieil animateur télé
lisa bruit ouais moi j'aime beaucoup
jean pierre foucault
et
alors jean claude brialy vos mémoires la
rivière des singes mais je suis débutant
ah oui débutant je sais ce sens vendu à
60 mille exemplaires c'est bien sans
mais six ans misé millions si médiocre
parce ce que vous allez à nous raconter
votre lacunes vie alors je vais faire le
pas la suite d'un petit journal a
compris la question ils ont ici qui est
venu pour avoir laissé en vie or j'ai
encore l'esprit be où il reste a du mal
à suivre
ah ça on va voir magnéto sérieusement
vous allez encore raconter votre vie une
fois non pas ma vie mes jambes je croise
ya pas longtemps j'ai obtenu une dame
qui m'a dit les compliments c'était très
charmant elle m'a dit je suis contente
de vous voir de votre vivant
oui alors si c'est vrai c'est vrai que
michal boni yayi
alors en attendant jean claude brialy
vous publié au cherche midi
les répliques les plus drôles du cinéma
à
comment ça s'est passé vous ai tout de
suite voir plein de sims imaginons donc
il faut dire que je suis très copain ami
avec les amis du cherche-midi oui très
bien qu'il travaille très bien qu'ils
font n'est pensé de bedos in spéciales
sas me disais hier louis jean yanne et
de coluche et d'autres lâchers chabrol
et prévôt et prévaut ce sont vraiment
des amis et mon lit voilà on a une
équipe qui a fait un répertoire et qui a
trouvé des répliques formidable dans des
films moyens quelquefois oui et je dois
dire que monsieur vous comme un musée en
lisant les épreuves j'en ai ajouté 2 3
et j'ai fait la préface c'est tout j'ai
pas fais pas mal à trouver du lait n'ont
rien volé c'est le bon boulot mais ils
ont bien à la télé pour dire que c'est
vachement nerfs voilà un qui est
vraiment très très très moche
est ce qu'il ya une réplique de vous
vous avez eu à prononcer dans un film et
que qui n'est pas dans le bouquin dont
il ya des fois des choses très bizarres
dans les cousins mon premier fils à papa
mon premier film populaire avec chabrol
paul gégauff avait écrit une petite
scène où je parle en allemand avec une
casquette de l'officier allemand un peu
à erich von stroheim mec a été
saisissant alors oui je faisais je le
compte toujours pour amuser chabrol
truffaut et godard avec une limitation
avec forem dans la grande illusion
gégauff lemay dallas dans le film
échappe au moment de tourner dit non
c'est pas bien ça va faire trop repasle
m alors je dis j'assiste petit à petit
numéro quand même d'acteurs alors il me
dit maintenant alors je tourne tout seul
sans chabrol qui va jouer au baby-foot
café du coin et j'écris très vite un
petit texte en allemand très simple il
vit nana in all eyes on u facteur de
moteurs etc
est ce cette scène a marqué le film dans
le monde entier et tout le monde me
disait c'est beau ce que tu dis de
goethe
mais les flics les plus drôles du cinéma
on cherche midi présenté par jean claude
brialy voilà alors vous êtes toujours
beaucoup d'activités 1
vous êtes patron des bouffes parisiens
directeur directeur des bouffes
parisiens et vous accueillez vous qu'on
produise est une pièce qui s'appelle les
oies du capital de philippe et cédric
dumont fait sur deux jeunes voilà green
tout très drôle c'est drôle mise en
scène de jacques de combat le pitch un
couple d'artisans quinquagénaire
reconverti dans le gardiennage
d'immeubles et pour s'évader de ce
quotidien un petit peu difficile
il regarde tous les jours le braz et des
passions à la télévision qui est une
série tv américaine dont les héros
finissent par devenir leur ami
voilà une certaine du sang foutu à la
porte les appels au secours mais c'est
très drôle
c'est complètement fou c'est burlesque
est plutôt que pour l'été les gens ont
envie de s'amuser puissant des gens
jeunes ils ne sont pas très connus et
quentin théâtre est fermée l'été c'est
comme une maison en deuil donc voilà
alors donc leur joli jeu non c'est très
joli et on entend bouquin croyait offrir
parce que oui et je te dis que c'était
très gentil merci vraiment numérotées
j'ai déjà donc quel est votre secret
pour faire autant de choses jean claude
brialy et vous on ne fait beaucoup de
choses que nous dans les airs c'est la
vanille et citizen kane la vieillesse
cnav en promo parce qu'ils ne parlent
qu'en situation
quel est votre secret pour avoir tant
d'amis garder tes amis près de toi et
tes tenues plus pas encore le par un
panel beaucoup de militants bouquin
l'économie est là mais il tend à la
maison c'est pareil non merde à la
maison d'arrêt s'est transcendé il aime
pas si monsieur est difficile le matin
il peut pas se réveiller pense que ça ne
peut pas se coucher
toujours pareil à une chose un trou 27
quel est votre secret pour rester pote
avec alain delon a c'est un vieux vieux
souvenir 1 oui c'est pour ça non non
c'est vrai que quand on a débuté avec
quelqu'un qu'on a passé des moments de
jeunesse ensemble mais je même
quelquefois je suis pas d'accord avec
lui je le lui dis alors on est fâché
pendant huit jours 1
mais ce qu'il a dit en disant que delon
en parlant de noël a dit la première
impression est toujours la bonne surtout
quand elle est mauvaise les amoureux
sont seuls au monde sa et l on sait dans
quoi ça parce que je me la suis animée
sont seulement avec louis jouvet dany
roberge et les deux
quel est votre secret pour avoir les
cheveux blancs à l'égard des blancs
comme ça la nature je couche avec lada
tu es et tu vois pas pareil quel est
votre secret pour ne pas vous endormir
un cérémonie des molières j'y vais pas
mais je trouve que quand j avais la
télévision je te dormi à 5 ans braga
quel est votre secret pour passer des
vacances gratuites à ramatuelle
je fais un festival et j'habite chez les
autres quel est votre secret pour vous
que pour supporter toutes les vieilles
dont vous vous occupez elles me font
rire
vous savez ce que m'a dit arrêté un jour
de répondre tout ça pour vous la
meilleure crème de beauté c'est la bonne
conscience à alors ça ça bouffe est à
tricher et quand on n'a pas su gérer la
bonne conscience en jean claude brialy
quand je pense à vous moi je pense à une
phrase si je m'en suis occupé jusqu'à la
fin ah oui hein c'est même ça c'est un
peu votre de vis oui oui vous pas les ai
donc les amis quoi qu'il arrive de lourd
disait ça d'ailleurs quelqu'un qui
depuis je reçois chez moi moi non
ce soir c'est votre tour georges le
voyait à 1